joining me now is Arkansas Senator Tom
Cotton author of the upcoming book Only
the Strong reversing the left's plot to
sabotage American power senator
we have just over 400 million barrels
left in this strategic petroleum reserve
the administration today made it clear
they have no plans of stopping their
release of more oil
explain why this is so dangerous
well it's obvious why they're doing that
Laura because they've got an election in
34 days and the price of gas has gone up
by a quarter in most places around the
country once again touching up against
four and five dollars a gallon but I
think you put it well and as I write in
Only the Strong the Democrats plan is
decline by Design we don't have five
dollar a gallon gas in this country by
accident it's not an unintended
consequence it's not in bad luck or the
evil machinations of oil company
Executives or OPEC it's because Joe
Biden and Progressive Democrats want gas
to be that expensive they want you to
get out of your gas guzzling SUV or
minivan they want Farmers to have to
stop using diesel for tractors and other
Farm instruments they think that you're
going to be able to replace all these
things with electric vehicles which by
the way really are co-powered or natural
gas powered or nuclear-powered Vehicles
because the electricity has to come from
somewhere and it doesn't come from the
sun when it's not shining or the wind
when it's not blowing and at root Laura
what this really is just gets back to
the far left anti-capitalist views I
mean energy literally Powers our modern
economy you know our founding fathers
didn't have much different quality of
life than Jesus's disciples did and
that's because 1800 years on the sources
of energy were the same it's only in the
last 200 years with fossil fuels first
coal and then oil and gas and then you
add nuclear power into that mix that
we've achieved true energy right the
senator what are the President Joe Biden
yeah let me just jump in here because
people want to know what next so let's
say you guys do manage to you know get
that seat and you take the majority
maybe you take a couple seats you take
the majority in the Senate what can
Republicans do to stop this madness if
anything
once you reclaim the majority
well at a minimum we can use our
spending power which we've got to do
pass every year to force the Biden
Administration to take certain actions
whether it's permitting new pipelines or
other oil and gas developments issuing
new permits and having new lease sales
we did this in the late Obama era once
we won back the Senate and the house in
2015 for instance we lifted the 40 year
old ban on oil exports going back to the
Jimmy Carter era speaking of democratic
presidents who intentionally tried to
hobble American Energy these are things
that steps that we can take to restore
America's oil and gas production that we
can encourage more drilling more
production not only for our own energy
needs but for those of our allies and
partners all around the world again by
the Biden Administration the Democrats
are doing this on purpose they recognize
the political danger of it though that's
why they're taking such risky steps like
this well they know it this is the only
reason yeah it's beyond obvious that's
what they're doing which brings me to my
next question
again if the Republicans take the
majority can we expect hearings in the
Senate that probe whether the motivation
for releasing millions and millions of
barrels from that spr and potentially
endangering the American people in a
time of emergency
whether that was done for political
reasons who was involved in that
decision making
uh to me that's a really important
question I'm not saying it's necessarily
an impeachable offense but it's pretty
damn important that we find out why that
was done
yeah Laura I think we need to get to the
bottom of it I think we know what we're
going to find out in the end I think
it's the political czars throughout the
administration reporting back to the
president and his political allies or
political aides in the White House well
that can't be allowed the Strategic
Patrol
strategic petroleum Reserve it's not
it's not the political right petroleum
reserve and the reason why they're
releasing this oil and gas is they
recognize even though they want gas to
be at five dollars a gallon they
recognize that this is a unique pain
point for most American families and
they got to at least appear to be taking
actions 34 days for an election that's
why they're also blaming OPEC and
blaming evil oil companies for trying to
drive up the price of oil in this
country but that directly translates
back to their own failed energy policies
I just imagine throughout the hurricane
like hurricane Ian yeah right I mean I
think about a hurricane like hurricane
Ian well they're defrauding the American
people that's not their oil to play with
that's our oil collectively and they're
playing politics with just that one
issue I mean that is a Republicans have
got to get to I don't think we can
assume anything I think it has to be
proven that this was a calculated
political move which is endangering the
future of America and I want to know who
was responsible I want to see the emails
and I think you guys are perfectly
positioned if you get the Senate to take
charge of this matter because we we
can't let this happen again this is too
important Senator I can't wait to read
your book thank you so much
[Music]